buenos dias a liliana pues efectivamente
hoy se llevó a cabo el segundo consejo
de ministros- uno que ya había tenido
lugar el día de ayer a martes y ahora
pues normalmente en este consejo de
defensa del día de hoy pues se
discutieron ya de las medidas después de
todas las discusiones que ha tenido el
primer ministro ron castex con los
diferentes sindicatos con los líderes
políticos a también a del país para
tener un consenso por ahora se sabe que
hay digamos dos medidas sobre la mesa
por una parte pues es un toque de queda
que sea un poco más estricto que no
comience a las 9 de la noche como
actualmente sino a las 7 y que sea para
todo el país pero en realidad parece que
la medida o la decisión que parece estar
tomada pues es la de un nuevo
confinamiento que sería menos estricto
que el que se vivió y en el que se
decretó a partir del mes de marzo pasado
por ahora lo que quiere el presidente de
macon sobre todo es que los colegios
permanezcan abiertos a pesar de ese
posible el confinamiento y también pues
los diferentes servicios esenciales
además de también los supermercados y
demás cosas así esenciales pero él pues
si quiere
digamos preservar un poco que se realice
pues esta educación para los niños sobre
todo digamos hasta octavo nivel de
secundaria y ya lo que son los liceos y
las universidades puede ser si será a
distancia natalia estas medidas pasarán
a voto mañana en el parlamento que se
espera a esa votación
así es un ave después emanuel manjón dé
a conocer estas medidas que pues será a
las 8 de la noche hora local desde aquí
desde el palacio del elíseo pues habrá
un voto por la mañana en la asamblea
nacional y luego en a la tarde será en
el en el senado un voto que se espera
pues de todas maneras no es vinculante
así que las decisiones que finalmente
tome el el gobierno del día de hoy pues
ya digamos que serán dejamos firmada sí
y ya pues tomadas pero de todas maneras
ya se sabía que la mayoría de los
diferentes diputados y demás en el
parlamento pues estaban de acuerdo con
un nuevo confinamiento sobre todo cuando
son cada vez más las voces sobre todo de
expertos las que se han levantado para
pedir que ésta sea la medida que se tome
y no se continúe con el toque de queda
porque en realidad según los estudios
pues el confinamiento el que debería
funcionar para hacer finalmente pues una
vez más bajar esa curva de contagios en
el país daría pues usted estará atenta a
la información y por supuesto con usted
le contaremos a la audiencia france24 lo
que se anuncie en horas de la noche